que ça vous arrive de rentrer chez vous
les mains vides jamais là puis 35 fois
qu'ils ont fait
allez vous songez que jamais vous ne
vous promenez les bras ballants et que
vous ne reculer devant aucune chance
je teste 5,6 kg
ainsi tous les jours trois quarts se
prêtait pas facile mais faut il pas une
solution
non il n'y a pas d'autre solution que
vous limitez vos milo mais manche et à
qui on fait si c'est bien on voulait
vraiment gagner
vous voyez ci qu'ils ont aussi effectué
en battant les clientèles assez spécial
vous avez les gens qui prendront
facilement le métro avec un escabeau et
d'autres qui prendront un taxi intention
était un petit paquet de mouchoirs il
remarqué mme jour l'homme les mains
vides et bien désemparés
c'est très compliqué ça nous arrive
bah oui parfaitement ça n'est pas sa
taille normale
on va mettre d'infoman village heures
qu'est ce que c'est que les petites
culottes
qu'est-ce que vous transportez là je
pense mort des boyaux je pense force et
warmeriville
les williams sacrée ce combiné un arbre
comme ça chez face à 20 kg méfiez vous
aussi de certains porteurs de pétain qui
sera dans le box comme les gants de boxe
bah oui quand les bossus servi à bon
prix et vous vous promenez souvent avec
comme ça c'est pour rendre la monnaie ou
fillon
qu'est-ce que vous transportez monsieur
et/ou d'où venez vous je sors de
l'atelier je rentre au magasin mais pour
combien une dizaine de millions vous
n'êtes pas accompagné on ici j'ai
rires avec moi pas de policiers non ben
on monde des compacts et les mots papier
avec les poignets surtout pas de dire
pourquoi c'est l'enfance l'habitude des
paquets insolite est prise
m
et